wildfires are ravaging the western u.s
this year
and in california inspectors like these
are going door to door
making sure homeowners have a perimeter
of defensible space
between the house and the forest what
kind of dog you have
okay i cleared a lot of this out yeah
but i still have the back section to do
when we do our inspection we'll start at
the roof okay work down and then out
from the house
any uh branches that are overhanging the
house we want those cleared back 10 feet
okay
you as a homeowner might think i'm doing
the right thing
and i've cleared a little this or i've
cleared you know some
plants away from my house but the
defensible space inspectors have been
trained to notice
maybe something a homeowner hasn't this
is a new approach for california
which is desperate to find ways to
reduce the impact of wildfires
after a record fire year in 2020 but as
fires once again rage in parts of the
state and the western u.s
why are many experts questioning whether
california is prepared for another
explosive fire season
in 2020 wildfires burned a
record-breaking 10 million acres in the
western u.s
nearly half of that was in california
last year saw five of the six largest
fires in modern state history
with more than 10 000 structures
destroyed and 33 deaths
according to cal fire this year
conditions
fueled by climate change are even worse
according to climate scientists
much of the region is facing extreme
drought conditions
and heat waves have set record
temperatures
experts say fighting fires is not enough
michael huara directs the climate and
energy policy program at stanford
he says a new strategy for preventive
work and land management is needed to
reduce wildfire risk
what we're seeing is a sea change
in california at least in the way that
this problem is
is thought about that's why california's
fire agency
cal fire has this team of defensible
space inspectors going door to door
in regions like butte county where the
camp fire destroyed the town of paradise
in 2018.
small home improvements can be the
difference between a house burning or
not
your uh chimney over here you want 10
feet away from that
yeah just make sure that's kept clear
cal fire says they've done around 3
200 inspections in the county so far and
plan to get to 6 000 by the end of the
year
but for many it may be too little too
late in california more than 11 million
people live in areas that border wild
lands according to the u.s forest
service
focusing on preventive work is
challenging when firefighters have their
hands full
fighting active blazes across the state
fire agencies like cal fire are already
stretched and grappling with firefighter
burnout from a now year-long season
john gaddy is a fire captain in butte
county we're asking our men and women of
cal fire not only of cal fire but our
federal and local government
counterparts to
work longer harder summers and it's
taking their toll on them not only
mentally but physically
the federal government controls the
majority of california's forests
but is struggling to recruit and retain
firefighters according to the u.s forest
service
grassroots wildland firefighters an
advocacy organization
estimates 20 percent of permanent
firefighting positions at the forest
service
are unfilled cal fire says they added
almost 1400 new seasonal firefighter
positions this year
however the state says they relied
heavily on inmate fire crews
which have been dramatically reduced
because of recent prison reform
and the early release of many prisoners
during the pandemic
we're down 50 plus or minus percent or
fire crews statewide which
at the end of the day on some of these
larger fires the men and women of fire
the fire crews and the fire engines are
the ones that actually get the line
put in and contain and control these
fires
so if we have one large fire pretty much
our crews or the fire crews of cal fire
are utilized more resources
may be on the way president biden
recently pledged to hire more federal
firefighters
and increase the pay to at least 15
dollars an hour
but some experts think the government
should be spending as much on wildfire
risk reduction
as firefighting in his california budget
proposal
governor newsom called for two billion
dollars to reduce wildfire threats
much of it earmarked for work like this
cutting new fire breaks and thinning
overgrown forests
as well as removing dead and dying trees
that become tinder for massive blazes
fuel reduction crews like this one
working outside of oroville california
are on the job year round and the
urgency is clear
as the crew worked a fast-moving
wildfire started just miles away
wora is encouraged by the progress in
the state but he says the national
forest service is not doing enough
we should be spending as much to reduce
the to reduce the risk of wildfire as we
are
to fight it when it occurs and the
federal government is not
moving in the right direction the forest
service reduced their hazardous fuel
reduction budget by more than 200
million dollars in 2021
and while the proposed 2022 budget
represents a steep increase
it is still below pre-pandemic levels
budgets are policy as far as i'm
concerned
and they tell you what's important and
what's not important
and the forest service
proposed a hazardous fuel reduction
budget for the entire united states it's
smaller than california's budget
the national forest service didn't
respond to a request for comment
but in a recent senate hearing a forest
service official said the agency hasn't
had the resources
to carry out necessary prescribed
firework and that they needed to boost
their fuel management projects
we have to scale up our work by at least
two to four times what we're doing right
now
as summer progresses experts say little
can be done to mitigate the immediate
danger
but fire crews are still hoping for a
less exhausting and destructive season
are we ready to respond right now
absolutely i just don't want to see that
onslaught and
unfortunately i think the environment
being hotter and drier
and lack of precipitation and some of
the fires we've already seen
it doesn't look good